reputation might be defined as the claim
that one can make on the goodwill of
strangers it is what your name will mean
to those who don't know you who spend
almost no time thinking about you it's
what you'll get reduced to when you
aren't illuminated by love how your
reputation is assessed depends on the
extent to which you've fulfilled or
violated the ideals and aspirations of
your society most of us are properly
known to and liked by five to ten people
when it comes to everybody else
reputation is what will decide what we
will have been worth reputation can't
bias love but it can provide us with
those valuable proxies respect honor and
politeness those who are kind to us when
we have a reputation may not mean it but
they're at least making an effort not
all of us crave equally the warmth that
comes with a good reputation those with
a particularly strong lead for applause
tend to be those with a weak sense of
their own acceptability the chair of the
crowd is asked to compensate for an
innate feeling of shame we seek the
validation of the world when we are
inside unconvinced that we're quite
deserving the more we've been Milly ated
especially when young the more the good
will of strangers is going to matter and
conversely the more we've tasted genuine
affection the less interesting
reputation will be
reputation is gossamer-thin Oh like a
soapy bubble or an unstable chemical
compound some metaphor to suggest the
ease with which it can be torn or
destroyed it's so prone to disappear
because it isn't based on knowledge or
experience of one's deep self it's made
up of the candyfloss of hearsay and
third hands gossip that's it's the
unconscious supposition of people who
haven't thought very deeply about who
one is and have absolutely no wish to do
so either it's what people who don't
care about us think about us this is
what makes reputation so delightful when
it's going our way
our nobility becomes part of the
unthinking common sense of the whole
community but this is also what makes
things so very tricky when our
reputation falls apart the only way in
which our good name might be rescued in
the minds of others is if they gave us
some thought which is precisely what
they've never done before and are not
going to begin to now either
[Music]
reputation will rise and fall according
to how closely we track or depart from
the ideals of our society and these tend
to be pegged to financial success sexual
propriety to quorum marriage sobriety
the sanctity of family and the purity of
children or more of these ideals when
flats the harsher will be the penalties
fortunately we are all of us error-prone
animals or to put it more bluntly idiots
we should say sorry to the universe
every day given how we are were
impulsive greedy lustful vain and
selfish which means that every year a
small but significant section of the
population makes an apparently minor
mistake that causes terrible damage to
others and blows up their life along the
way not for nothing does Western
civilization have at its heart the
example of Greek tragedy which tells us
of averagely good people brought alone
are highly understandable everyday kinds
of folly for which they pay an ultimate
price
[Music]
the whole community hears in an instant
and one's done for the punishment maybe
financial or legal but the ultimate
damage is psychological one becomes a
pariah in the minds of all those who
don't think about us properly which is
almost everyone one is now a monster or
a numbskull for life from now on we're
going to need to be looked at through
the eyes of love before we ever stand a
chance of reemerging as in any way human
that is deserving of even a little pity
or understanding only through love can
we be remembered to have once been a
baby who was innocent who struggled and
who later made mistakes from passing
weaknesses rather than evil only through
love are there any other sides of the
story as a result all those who are not
our intimates become sources of surefire
damning the judgment we know from the
outset that they go to hate or condemn
us it becomes impossible to go to a
party or even walk down the street one
probably has to move town suicidal
thoughts become harder to push or when
ambitions have to change entirely
everything that depends on the minds of
people in general is now impossible what
people might think disappears from the
calculation it's a foregone conclusion
they'll think always that one is a demon
when the reputation lists rediscover
close friends and family and they almost
always do it isn't coincidental or a
cheap excuse it's because they can see
more clearly than ever that these are
the people the only people who know them
properly and can therefore examine them
with any degree of subtlety everyone
else once disappeared into a single word
of insult in older more religious
societies there was the possibility of
apology before a divine being a period
of penance and then eventually
forgiveness but that's one of the Handy
mechanisms we unknowingly dismantled
when we decided that God was
fiction in a secular world we've been
left with only one tool the legal system
which levies fines and prison sentences
but isn't in the business of restoring
reputation and doesn't get involved in
most of the areas which caused it to be
lost in the first place there is quite
literally in most cases no way to
recover reputation the sentence is the
life flow we suffer also because we live
in such a vast society's recovery of
reputation might have been possible when
we lived in tribes of a hundred or so
you could go around and explain things
in person tent by tent no such chance
but it's a case of having a few hundred
million minds to change so begins that
peculiar challenge leaving a life
without a reputation a feat in its way
as arduous as hanging on to a cliff face
with bare hands in high winds a few
moves do suggest themselves for a start
acceptance of oneself of the situation
of one's misdeeds and of the darkness
then the construction of a new kind of
communal life one built around
astonishing sincerity and vulnerability
one now has no option but to say it like
it is there's no need for yet more shame
a whole new set of friends is called for
before whom one can be truly oneself in
a way one perhaps never could be before
things fell apart
it helps immensely if these new friends
have themselves lost reputation
ex-convicts
are a great idea and fallen business
people and politicians they will have a
kindness to them open only to those
who've suffered infinitely for their
parents there is only so empathetic and
thoughtful that blameless people will
ever be animals are good too
they rarely judge the immense open
spaces of nature offer valuable
perspective as well as do history books
lots of thoughts have to be avoided in
order not to howl with agony it isn't
the life anyone would have wanted at the
high-water mark but it's a life
nevertheless and one we should all
contemplate whatever our situation to
prepare ourselves for the day which
can't be guaranteed never to come when
we might be forced to walk the earth
without the cloak of a reputation at the
school of life
we believe that confidence is a skill we
can all learn our confidence prompt
cards are designed to help us master
this essential skill click now to learn
more